every honor okay so we're gonna do a
reaction video today mom goes nuts over
her new Chewbacca masks I'm done sitting
like this this video went viral really
fast
yeah and I've heard about it on talk
shows I've never seen it though I
haven't either I was like you know what
we just watched a depressing video hmm
we need a laugh and I heard this videos
funny hey I'm I'm really excited to
share with you something I got okay I
went to Kohl's today I had to make a
couple returns and stuff didn't fit
surprisingly it was a little too big
thank you I know some of you may be
thinking the opposite shame no never no
shame it's all love it's all that okay
so here's what I found when I was at
Kohl's and I'd like to say that I bought
this for my son that would really really
want it and let's be honest so probably
confiscated from me confiscate that's a
word right okay so he'll probably take
it from me however this is mine like
when it's said and done at the end of
the day this is mine that I bought and
I'm gonna keep it for my own you can see
it kind of Star Wars then you're gonna
live okay so you guys do it up too great
I can't wait to show you okay um this is
part of my my birthday joy still
rejoicing in my birthday and so here's
what I got I'm gonna take it out of box
and I can't wait to show you
okay I'm gonna talking about and people
are literally looking at me like crazy I
don't even care okay so here it is huh
it may be a little tight it may be tight
on me I gotta undo it just a little bit
cold huh
stay patient people stay patient this is
gonna be worth it I promise maybe not
maybe not but it worth it to me
with lives so they should patient
alright we're doing good - good okay so
this is what I got once again this is
for me not for Duncan
not for cadence I mean I'll let them
play with it I'm not a bad mom I'm not a
jerk but and I want to see at the end of
the day then go in there toy box it goes
in my room so here we go I gotta take
this blue glasses for it so yes now
watch me my mouth actually moves
this is worth every my god I could talk
here Oh
Oh birthday present ever to myself oh my
goodness
y'all have an incredible day it's a
simple job oh my gosh uh I was awesome
that was so freaking funny that was
hilarious
that joy that she has just like totally
infectious transferred over yeah I mean
despite the fact that it was like a
funny thing on its own the show back up
to bag of ice is like really well made
like it only opens a little bit when she
opens her mouth a little bit or opens
all the way like like that's hilarious
but the fact that like she got so much
yeah so much stayed around as you like
in and then like out in the lane turn to
the side like a kid in a candy store
oh my god I was delightful what was her
name and his pain funny yeah she's a
sweetheart I wonder what our kids think
about her kids are so embarrassed half
the video was just buildup
yeah half the video was her just being
like you're gonna love this
you're gonna rub it you can see a real
joy a real Star Wars fan inside of her
too yes oh my god yes I actually heard
that that mask was sold out in like two
days
after this video I can believe oh me too
hold on we're gonna watch Tyrone's
reaction vodka mask
Hey all right just like in the beginning
okay I went to holistic and make couple
returns surprisingly it was a little too
big
Thank You Sara go shake it's all love
it's all though okay so here's what I
found when I was at Kohl's and I'd like
to say that I bought this for my son it
reminds me my mom Maria
the other con i tuoi box egos my ring so
here we go yes
it's a simple tool thank you
hi alas this heart is a longtime lady
Tyrone Wow no it's so funny
I've never seen you this good before
I've never seen you this good you guys
snorting it's hilarious
oh I'm really funny Wow
oh and then to watch Tyrone much time
around this is [ __ ] yeah and then I also
got to watch her video yeah so much
laughter oath is that we've all heard
interwebs
she said internet web her networks oh
god so genuine wow I'm exhausted I know
I exhausting cheeks hurt I am exhausted
that was hilarious I love her I'm in
love with her that woman is just a joy -
dude that was amazing humans I needed
that Wow yeah I mean I can't believe I
haven't watched this video I'd already
no one told me it was that funny no one
told about it is something on YouTube
video - how do I know okay like she
likes Chewbacca like I'm like I like
Star Wars but not like a lot God so
funny man she was like Ben I'm like wait
Late Show whoa dude she's like that's
why it's because she is so genuine so
Jenny one it's what we want from YouTube
God what did she say she said confiscate
convinced key
- Skyy yeah that's a word we've all had
that mom this seems like a real sweet
mother yes
like she deserves so much she does you
know I want to be to the world I want to
pay her money have her on your show oh
my god never on here have
guess I'm like a vine compilation' and
we could do a reaction of her oh my god
making out with me with the Chewbacca
masks on can you imagine that
to be hot huh yeah make it out song with
the Chewbacca masks I wonder if you like
smells really plasticky doesn't matter
okay doesn't matter
steggy listen guys we're gonna do the
challenge today become a reject
Rhianna White has a channel gaming
channel it's good channel check it out
it's really good
playing uncharted Uncharted fun game and
she has an Instagram Twitter Facebook
periscope snapchat periscope now I've
had a periscope in fact I got it as soon
as someone mentioned that it existed
because I wanted to get my username and
normally occasionally I usually use it
for conventions I'm doing a lot of
conventions this summer you're going to
VidCon I'm gonna make on so go to VidCon
and meet Briana guys San Diego comic-con
whoa Samuel you oh yeah I am for my
movie occupants screening at the Film
Festival there you jelly should be
pretty excited about it
yeah it's prequel movie just won second
place it yeah at Phoenix Comic Con like
pretty cool okay Brown you're so jealous
much else macho he's so Jill he's so
jealous [ __ ] you have much else
mm-hmm exceedingly jealous jealous
you're jealous
cats cat oh thank you did oh she hates
you yeah that's how I got back at you Oh